les pays arabes voisins d'Israël sont
très inquiets des conséquences de ce qui
s'est passé à la fois de l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas et de ce qui se
passe actuellement à Gaza parce qu'il
redoute un transfert des Palestiniens de
sisjordanie et de la bande de Gaza dans
leur pays le dramatique conflit qui
oppose israélien et Palestiniens
bouleverse la recomposition du
Moyen-Orient le rapprochement d'Israël
avec les pays arabes sunites est
désormais compromis Georg mal Bruno
expliquez-nous les mécanismes qui sont à
l'œuvre depuis le 7 octobre entre les
acteurs de la région ces pays concerné
c'est d'abord la Jordanie le roi
Abdallah de Jordanie a déclaré ce matin
à Berlin que ses lignes rouges à lui pas
de réfugiés palestiniens de s Jordanie
en Jordanie et pas de réfugiés
palestiniens de Gaza en Égypte ça veut
dire que la Jordanie ne veut pas servir
de réceptacle aux Palestiniens dont
Israël ne veut pas vous rappeler que la
Jordanie qui a signé la paix avec Israël
en 1994 a déjà reçu à l'issue des
précédentes guerres israëlo-arabes des
centaines de milliers de Palestiniens
puisqu'on considère que la moitié au
moins de la population de Jordanie est
composée de réfugié Palestiniens
aujourd'hui la situation est assez
inflammable aussi à Man donc ligne rouge
clairement fixée par le roi de Jordanie
c'est la même chose pour l'Égypte Abdel
fatas Sissi le président égyptien a
déclaré il y a quelques jours a appelé
les palestinens de Gaza à rester sur
leur terre l'Égypte ne veut pas voir
arrivver des centaines de milliers de
Palestiniens qui sont déjà appelés par
Israël à quitter le nord de la bande de
Gaza pour aller au sud frontalier de
l'Égypte avoir arrivé 1 million ou 2
million de Palestiniens de Gaza dans le
désert du sinï et que l'Égypte soit un
peu le le la variable d'ajustement comme
la Jordanie du conflit
israélopestinien ce à quoi s'ajoute pour
l'Égypte aujourd'hui la question
humanitaire l'Égypte est prête à envoyer
de l'aide humanitaire dans la bande de
Gaza mais pour ça il faut les corridors
humanitaires Israël n'en veut pas donc
ça coince encore à ce niveau-là sachant
que l'Égypte ferme sa frontière avec
Gaza puisqu'elle ne veut pas elle craint
cet exode massif de de Palestiniens chez
elle ensuite il y a un troisème pays
très important qui scrute avec attention
la situation c'est l'Arabie Saoudite qui
était engagé dans des pour parler en vue
d'une normalisation avec Israël c'est
pour parler sont gelé l'Arabie saoudite
a durci sa position à l'égard d'Israël
elle souhaite qu'il y ait justement une
réponse je dirais arabe et une réponse
sur la question palestinienne c'est la
raison pour laquelle probablement avec
d'autres responsable arabe ont transmis
à Anthony blinken un message en disant
nous ne serions pas opposés pas du tout
à ce que le Hamas soit éradiqué mais ce
qu'on veut c'est une réponse politique
au problème palestinien d'où la
déclaration ce matin intéressante d'un
responsablearmée israélienne qui a dit
il faut penser à l'après Gaza en
coordination avec les pays arabes
ensuite vous avez d'autres pays qui sont
sur une position plus dure et en
particulier le Liban et la Syrie avec
derrière eux l'Iran le Liban abrite le
hzbollah milice chite financé armée par
l'Iran qui est hostile à Israël qui fait
monter la pression hein depuis une
semaine vis-à-vis de d'Israël le
Hezbollah est allié je dirais
logistiquement même politiquement avec
le le Hamas et derrière le Hezbollah le
ministre iraniens des Affaires
étrangères ce matin le guide suprême
iranien Ali khameney a appelé à une fin
immédiate des bombardements israéliens
sur la bande de Gaza la crainte c'est
que l'Iran et ses proxis ses relais
interviennent dans la guerre et ouvre un
nouveau front sur le nord à partir du
Liban ou éventuellement à partir de la
Syrie puisque ces dernières années et
bien des relais iraniens en Syrie ont
établi des bases qu'Israël a les a
bombardé quasiment je dirais
cotidiennement et donc il pourrait y
avoir aussi l'ouverture d'un nouveau
front à partir de la Syrie l'Iran ne
fera pas directement la guerre à Israël
puisqueelle s'est créé cette cet arc de
de relais qui lui permet de de de de
peser de manière asymétrique mais l'Iran
faut pas l'oublier a beaucoup de comptes
à régler avec Israël parce que Israël
lui a assassiné un certain nombre
d'experts nucléaire la espionné
copieusement donc on est sur cette
aujourd'hui sur cette cette position là
avec des pays arabes plutôt sunides qui
sont attachés eu aussi à la cause
palestinienne mais qui ont durci leur
position contre Israël pour ne pas
laisser justement l'axe dit de la
résistance pro-iranien récupérer donc
l'Iran pays non arabe récupérer une
cause arabe qui était cher à tous les à
tous les Arabes c'està-dire la cause
[Musique]
palestinienne